name's Allen Barry Allen this is a party
for criminals it's my stories up to
something
fighting zone okay what do we do
your battles a good show you know and
all the hub of saving your keisters
never got to ask what the hell you were
doing down there a 1940's no one says
keisters Nash if you would just tell us
what you're looking for down there we
might be able to help you all right
tomorrow morning at o'clock tunnels
bringing all fancy team why should we do
that
because I know how to save Barry Allen
you must be the monitor how do you know because no human would actually wear
something so ridiculous you ate for the
world he lost and I possessed the power
to restore
you can bring back where's the recovery
of your universe will require a single
task
what kind of task
you must betray Oliver Queen
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my video for the flash
season 6 episode 6 trailer crisis on
Infinite Earths scenes from arrow and
flash this week and the new Batman news
for Robert Pattinson zhh Batman they
just confirmed a couple big characters
so we'll break it all down there's a
whole bunch of Easter eggs in this too
in teasers for crisis on Infinite Earths
we're still doing that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your best
theory about crisis on Infinite Earths
on the video I'll start with a trailer
in the footage then I'll talk about the
Batman stuff so just careful for
spoilers for the flash and arrow this
week if you have not seen those episodes
as you can see they're doing a James
Bond style episode they even have James
Bond music playing under it with
elongated man teaming up with the flash
which means that they'll probably tease
more of the suit did nice storyline any
time one of the other side characters
gets paired up with the flash for the
main storyline they always get to push
way deeper on whatever their arc is for
the season and for him it's just the
suit didney arc and as you can see
they're bringing back the ultraviolet
villain from episode 2 so there might be
some more Easter eggs for a black hole
from the flash rebirth comics but we
start with Nash wells saying that he has
a plan to save Barry Allen so the whole
idea is that he seems the kind of a
dirtbag at first but they're slowly
winning him over to the team he doesn't
want to have anything to do with the
council of Wells but he wants that sweet
sweet eternium honey that apparently the
monitor is either hoarding or has access
to because why else would he be trying
to follow the monitor because Joe
mentions the monitor knee says you know
Mar novo and he gets ready to give him
this big explainer before elongated man
comes and stops him so it sounds like he
might try to steal some eternium from
the monitor and there also might be
something in his special secret stash
that can help them save Barry the whole
thing with eternium from the comic books
is that it's actually shards from the
rock of eternity which is a huge Suzanne
in Black Adam Easter Egg I don't know
how much they're going to get into that
during the crossover so maybe just some
small Easter eggs for the Shazam
characters because I don't expect to see
the rock or Zachary Levi pop up in the
crossover the whole thing with the arrow
scenes is that Oliver is actually trying
to build a weapon to destroy the monitor
if he turns on them as the prophecy he
got last week foretold there was a book
that belonged to the League of Assassins
thousands of years ago the monitor
visited someone from the League of
Assassins and they recorded in his
journal that he thought that he might be
responsible
for the coming calamity quote-unquote
crisis on Infinite Earths so Oliver is
operating on the assumption that the
monitor might double-cross them at some
point he doesn't know anything about the
anti-monitor yet they haven't give him
that explainer yet so without any
context Oliver pushes forward giving
mr. terrific a sample to analyze a fabric
that had been grazed by the antimatter
wave that destroyed earth to a couple
weeks ago remember the whole reason that
Oliver was there was to steal Dorf star
particles for something that the monitor
was building and it might be the cosmic
towers that appear during crisis on
Infinite Earths he might be building a
version of that but you also have to
consider that that prophecy might become self-fulfilling and if Oliver's actions
he takes to avoid the monitor going
crazy on them actually lead to the
monitor going crazy on them then you had that big twist seen with Black Canary
being visited by someone who looks like
the monitor saying that she could get
earth to back it's in my power all you
have to do is betray Oliver Queen he
even looks like he kind of has a smirk
on his face while he's telling her that
like he enjoys the idea that she might
betray Oliver which does not
characteristically seem like the Marno
vu monitor that we've seen the last
couple of years
so either the monitor is lying to
everyone about preventing crisis on
Infinite Earths and he is
double-crossing them or this is not the
monitor Marno vu and it's really the
anti-monitor masquerading as him or at
some other rogue monitor that might wind
up becoming the anti-monitor if you've
never read comic book crisis on Infinite
Earths these monitors are a race of
beings that all look like this they all
have the weird chops and the jowls they
have the weird haircuts but they do have
subtle differences in their faces and
hairstyles the TV show might just be
changing that in order to mislead us so
that you think that this is the monitor
but surprise twist it winds up being
someone else
remember Martian Manhunter 's brother is
kind of evil and he's a shape-shifter so
there is an evil shapeshifter that could
be working with the anti-monitor to
mislead the heroes also fun fact during
crisis on Infinite Earths the actor
who's playing the monitor this person
here is also playing the anti-monitor
when he goes full comic book
anti-monitor looking like the mobius
from the comics from the antimatter
universe he just posted this
behind-the-scenes picture a little while
ago now that doesn't confirm that this
is the anti-monitor but in the comics
harbinger
who's played by Lila on the TV show gets
mind-controlled by the anti-monitor and
is forced to the monitor so
Superman and all the heroes that are
left are forced to find a way to fight
the anti-monitor by themselves without
the monitors help but in the comics the
monitor and the anti-monitor are two
completely different characters
there's nobody masquerading as the
anti-monitor he always looked like this
with the crazy face but early theory if
this isn't a shapeshifter may be
Oliver's antimatter weapon gets used on
the anti-monitor and instead of
him it's supercharges him and makes his
face look like this but it still doesn't
explain what happens to the monitor
because in all these big fight scenes I
have not seen the monitor charging the
field with them it's just the heroes
versus the anti-monitor so either at
some point they wind up him off
like they did in the comics or he winds
up turning into the anti-monitor which
would be a big twist but moving into
Batman news so the big news about the
Batman movie is that Andy Serkis
is being locked down as their new Alfred
I was super surprised when I saw this
interesting choice not somebody who I
would have expected for that role I
would have expected him for a role that
required more prosthetics like the
penguin or something else or one of the
villains from his rogues gallery but I
do think that he can do a great job with
a character because he has done a lot
more darker noir movies and television
shows and that seems like it's going to be
the tone of the new Batman film the
other thing they just announced is
probably even bigger they just announced
the Colin Farrell is being locked down
as their new Oswald Cobblepot penguin
which again is not someone I would have
ever thought of for that role normally
when you think of Colin Farrell you
think of it maybe as a Harvey Dent
two-face but there's no mention of what
he would look like and if they'd use any
prosthetics or motion capture to modify
his face to give him more of a
comic-book penguin look so of no idea
what he's actually going to look like as
that character but currently right now
they have Robert Pattinson as the Batman
Jeffrey Wright as Commissioner Gordon
not detective Gordon apparently he's
supposed to be Commissioner Gordon when
this story begins in there doing the
Batman the Animated Series thing where
all of the villains like two-face
Riddler penguin are already operating in
Gotham City when the story begins
they're not going to start with their
origin stories and build them up you'll
already see penguin being full penguin
and Riddler being full Riddler when the
story begins they just announced zoe
kravitz is their Selina Kyle
woman and then obviously paul dano as
their Edward Nash tune Riddler he just
the original version of the comic book
Riddler I've already done a video about
that so I'll link it at the end of this
they're still looking for their Harvey
Dent two-face he will be in the movie
and they'll probably announced that
before the end of the year there will be
other minor characters they announced
after they start shooting they usually
don't cast those minor roles till right
before they need them to shoot those
scenes but they will confirm all the
mains really soon and after that give us
the first look at Robert Pattinson snoo
Batman costume the costume designer that
they got is the one that did the
original blade movie he's done Star Wars
in the new Star Trek movies a whole
bunch of other stuff so he's pretty
solid he'll probably make a pretty cool
Batman costume and given that it's more
of a detective thriller and wash story
I'm expecting the new Batman suit to be
way more toned down and less armor
looking than the last few versions from
say Christian Bale's Dark Knight Batman
and Ben Affleck's bat suit even though
he did have a very cloth looking version
of the suit his version of Batman was
just way more hulking in giant than the
Robert Pattinson version is going to be
I would say his new bat suit is going to be
even less armor looking than Michael
Keaton's Batman suits I'd be totally
cool if they wanted to go with the
classic blue and grey but I think that
they'll probably stick with black post
all your theories in the comments below
what do you think that Robert Pattinson
'he's new batman suit is going to look
like which version are they going to be
mostly inspired by congratulations tebya
smolka you're the giveaway winner from
my last big flash video please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your details everyone click here for
the brand new Rick and Morty's season 4
trailer and click here for that new
Batman Riddler video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight!